Multilayer perceptron is a classic
feed-forward artificial neural network.
It is one of the core component of some deep
learning algorithms. Not all algorithms in
deep learning use a feed-forward artificial neural
network, but many do. Another way to look at this,
is that a multilayer perceptron is a connected
series of nodes, where each node represents
a function. This connected series of node,
create what is called a directed acyclic graph.
Meaning that there is directionality between
the nodes and no node will ever be revisited.
This all starts
with an input layer. Let's use the Titanic data
set example. There are four nodes here and each
node would represent a feature that we want to
use to predict whether somebody survives or not.
These could be age, ticket class, cabin and
sex. Next there's a hidden layer that we're
representing with five nodes here. But this hidden
layer could contain 10 nodes, a hundred nodes,
or even a thousand nodes. Now each of these nodes
represents some function. What happens is, we take
each of our input nodes, representing features and
we pipe those into each node in the hidden layer.
What's happening here is each node, or function,
in the hidden layer is getting each input feature.
So age, ticket class, cabin and sex are
passed into each node in the hidden layer.
You could view each of these nodes as
something like logistic regression.
So, more or less a logistic regression model
would be fit for each node made with slightly
different weights.
Then we have an output layer. And
here we're going to have two nodes.
Either a person survived, or they did not survive,
using the example of our Titanic data set.
Now we have each node in the hidden layer,
outputting to each node in the output layer.
Let's take a step back and just isolate one node
in the hidden layer to understand what's happening
here. You can see it's receiving the four inputs.
Then this one node in the hidden layer will
basically fit some model, or learn some aspect of
the data. Then based on that model that it learns,
it'll make some prediction about whether somebody
survived or not. Maybe it's 70% likelihood that
they survived, 30% likelihood that they did not.
That's just one individual node in the hidden
layer. The same process can repeat for each of
the five nodes in the hidden layer, and you get
a final prediction of the likelihood of a given
person surviving.
As you can imagine, these can be incredibly
powerful. As you see in this example, you're
essentially aggregating the predictions
of five different models all together.
This allows the overall model, to learn some
really powerful relationships in the data.
When should you consider using
a multi-layer perceptron?
Up to this point we've suggested using
logistic regression and SVM only for
a categorical or binary target variable.
One nice aspect of multilayer perceptrons
is that they're really powerful for both
classification and regression. In other words,
they're useful for both categorical and continuous
target variables. As mentioned earlier, the way
multilayer perceptrons are constructed allow them
to learn very complex relationships in the data.
If you have complex relationships in your data or
all you care about is performance and you don't
care about training time or interpretability,
then this might be a good tool for your problem.
There are a lot of hyperparameters to tune.
If you want to have a lot of control over the
training process, multilayer perceptrons might
be a good method to explore.
When should you not use it? Multilayer
perceptrons are a core component of deep learning.
You may have also heard that deep learning is
really good for tasks like image recognition or
time series. That does not mean that multilayer
perceptrons are good for these kinds of problems.
There are specific algorithms within deep
learning, like convolutional neural networks,
that are very good for image recognition. So,
you should not use multilayer perceptrons for
this kind of work.
If you care about transparency or significance
of predictors, you also shouldn't use multilayer
perceptrons. They're kind of like black boxes.
You pass in inputs and it returns predictions
and it's quite difficult to understand what's
going on internally that is generating those
given predictions for any model. This is another
algorithm just like SVM that isn't great for a
quick benchmark model.
Multilayer perceptrons require more
hyperparameter tuning than some other algorithms,
so you need to spend time doing that
before you can expect to get a good model.
It can also take a while to train, though not
quite as long as SVM. So, this isn't a great
choice as a quick benchmark model.
Lastly, you should not use multilayer perceptrons
if you have very limited data available. They
really thrive when you have a lot of data. If
you don't have a lot of data, you're probably
better off exploring other options as the time
investment likely won't pay off in performance.
For instance, you might be better off with SVM or
logistic regression when you have limited data.
In summary, multilayer perceptrons are often
the best tool for the job when you have a lot of
data and you really only care about performance.
But they're not ideal if you have limited data,
if you don't have much time or compute power,
or you really care about the transparency of
the model in understanding its predictions.